through the power of mantra or
affirmation you can actually shape and
create patterns within your mind so then
we fully sort of develop anger you can't
see the reality in the world out there
today people have a wrong idea of
success wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
so love you and I believe a lifeboat
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how to 10x your life with
the help of these monk secrets enjoy
okay let's kick it off with secret
number one shape your mind with
dhandapani so subconscious is very
moldable and you know sits sits back
here in your head and through the power
of mantra affirmation you know in
sanskrit language they call it mantra
you can actually shape and create
patterns within your mind and I'm
showing you run and again I'm assuming
that you say like I can do this right
you don't say like I know I'm gonna fail
sure right and and through that
repetition you create patterns in your
mind so if you follow a precise
technique and system you'd create
patterns in your subconscious which then
become extremely magnetic and start to
attract like-minded people towards you
so I used those techniques I had a firm
a Shinto mantras that I would say every
morning and every night with and what
they consists of is concise charts of
positive words so you never say
something like oh I would like to be
surrounded by successful people but if I
don't it's okay that's not a mantra like
you know I will surround myself with
financially successful entrepreneurs who
teach me how to be successful right and
then it comes to the second thing that's
important is a clear visualization you
have to have a clear visual concept of
what the end product is going to look
like and then the third part of it
that's the most important component is
the feeling you have to feel it because
feeling is emotion in motion is energy
and energies magnetic how do you feel
you remember a feeling of what it's like
to experience sitting with someone who's
a successful entrepreneur spending time
with them walking away and asking
yourself how that felt really great I
learned so much and could really use
these techniques and helping my business
like for example with you in a race you
can remember the feeling of what it's
like right so if you're doing an
affirmation for your next race you say I
will win this race so I can win this
race and you and you visualize that
feeling you had when you won the last
race exactly you visualize yourself
going through the little ribbon okay
your race is that right you're walking
through the ribbon you are barbed wire
in our case Bob why exactly lays a fence
going through that and and then the
feeling what the feeling like was the
feeling is like to win that so you hole
all three in your mind at the same time
and you repeat it it creates a pattern
in subconscious which then becomes
extremely magnetic it vibrates at a
particular frequency of that success and
it attracts
things of a similar nature secret number
to be calm with the Dalai Lama I tell
you you should realize the anger may
bring some kind of energy a short moment
a short period but that energy is
actually blind energy and anger really
destroy your positive part of your brain
which can judge the right or wrong so
when we fully sorrow develop anger we
can't see the reality so that energy
move or dread but that energy is blind
by energy so in order to face the
problem our method should be as I
mentioned earlier realistic in order to
carry realistic method you must know the
reality when we look the reality when we
investigate the reality our mind should
be calm otherwise we cannot see the
thing objectively so in order to use
human intelligence properly our mind
should become so thinking this line
anger they say firstly destroy your
inner peace secondly destroy your
ability to to investigate the reality so
you think this line then once you have
career sort of awareness and is no use
only destruction also if you want to
have more confidence check out my 254
series they're free the link to join is
in a description below it's easy to make
a buck very hard to make a difference
it's quite amazing how we work ourselves
up so much with increasing the standard
of living that we forget to increase the
standard of my life and whenever you're
updating to a higher version of your
self you have to be able to give the
best of yourself to it
secret number three have compassion
would take not harm if you think that
the compassion making you weak you have
wrong compassion may cause a man a
person who sacrificed his life to save
other people and we have to really find
what is compassion it's very powerful
and we have to embody that kind of
energy you know you know you know we
realize we had to really take people
about this you have to show what
compassion can achieve when when someone
is angry he's been burned by the fire of
anger and if he knows how to practice
compassion anger will die down very
quickly and it looks much better much
more beautiful much much more attractive
that is why we had two example 5 is
embody that practice of compassion in
order to persuade other people to to do
the same compassion help us to sleep
well
compassion protects us better than guns
and bombs and money many of us think
that we are safer to we if we have more
money
but you can lose your money
very easily but compassion is a kind of
energy that can help protect you much
much more effectively than than money
and compassion help you to relax and
your body has more capacity to heal
itself compassion help you to be
pleasant to be loving and you can
restore communication with other person
easily if you have compassion in
yourself you understand the other person
your compassion can help you do your
business better because you are in good
relationship with other people including
your employees so you can list a lot of
qualities of compassion and we should
have a man a woman a community of men a
woman practicing community practice
income combustion like that in order to
show people that compassion is something
very powerful secret number 4 find the
right balance with the work appalled us
in the world out there today people have
a wrong idea of success people think
success means achievement and people
think success means having all what the
world is promoting to you so the more
you have the more successful you are and
the more happier you are that's a
completely wrong idea of success that
people have now when you're wanting to
achieve and you wanting to get the best
and you wanting to get there all the
time obviously have to work hard
loads of people are putting in 14 16 18
hours of work not prioritizing their
health not prioritizing their hobbies
not prioritizing their family not
prioritizing their spirituality not
prioritizing their unwinding them saying
how much do you prioritize there's so
many things seeking your attention is
there a risk of people spreading
themselves too thin and how do you
figure that out how do you how do you
fly I don't think so it's a question of
spreading yourself out I think it's a
question of finding the right balance
irritability and lack of satisfaction is
is
is an outcome often life out of balance
you know a life out of balance now it's
like it's like when you were an artist
is wanting to make a painting or a
pencil sketch and if he's sharpening the
pencil someone comes in says hey man you
are wasting your time sharpening a
pencil but unless I sharpen the pencil
whatever you do is going to be extremely
blunt so if you even want to be
effective at work and achieve it's
better that you be internally focused if
you are not focused and if you're not
internally mentally stable your output
at the workplace is low as well I'm
saying that if you prioritize those
things that mean to you you work on
yourself you open your internal self the
consequence of that would be will be
super productive and less number of
hours people are taking much longer to
do something that they could have done
in much shorter amount of time because
they're distracted they're not focused
they're not together
what you're saying is very simple but
it's not easy
absolutely so let's cut to the chase
sure give it all to our viewers a few
practical solutions to continue to focus
on oneself and not be distracted by the
noise that there are some tactical
speakers
number one start taking an inventory
regularly okay don't just go with the
flow if you're not even paying attention
to you if you're not even cognizant if
you're not even identifying those areas
you're not going to work on them so
first identify that I need to work on
this understand that this is a priority
step two is regularly take time out if
you don't take a break you're simply
leading to a breakdown a break is going
to help you get to a break true but a
lack of break is going to get you to a
breakdown if you have ever read the book
the monk who sold his Ferrari it's a guy
who's just working achieving putting his
200% and gets a cardiac arrest at a
young age in the courtroom what is it on
the part you've achieved everything and
you know massive failure because you
couldn't work on your life so - it's
take a break now you might say oh man
I'm really busy how am I going to take a
break which basically means you don't
got it right if you can't take a break
you're leading to a breakdown
prioritize that break so you can achieve
a breakthrough yeah I know breaks are
not easy even mean my life is 150 to 200
sometimes 250 flights a year exactly
that's how much I travel how do you take
a break I have learned the art of
unwinding on the go how do you do that
you have to do it on the go prioritize
it listen to your favorite music read
your favorite book eat your favorite
food
you know meditate while or you're on the
go sit there I don't mind this then
learn the art of cutting off from the
surroundings while you're on you sitting
in the car driving back home you're
sitting on a 17 hours flight to New York
you know what are you going to do
although 17 hours learn the art of
cutting off from the surroundings and
going within I do that and secret number
five the last one before a very special
bonus clip is wake up with Jai Shetty
awakening signifies that we're asleep
when you say we have to become woke or
awakened or any of these words that were
using now right rising above it all
means that we're asleep so even though
we think we're awake we're saying we're
consciously asleep and therefore the
earth people around us conscious
creators everyone you've mentioned are
simply all trying to wake each other up
and we all know that when you don't wake
up in the morning the alarm just has to
get louder and louder and louder and if
the alarm doesn't get louder and louder
and louder and louder we don't wake up
and so if you see the earth in a state
of emergency if you see the environment
in a state of emergency if you're
looking at the world in a state of
emergency it's because the alarm is just
getting louder and louder and louder and
trying to say wake up like like wake up
you know and so for me that's the
process that we all need to go through
just as it's tough to wake up in the
morning after you've been out to a party
you've had too much to drink you've done
something that you weren't proud of or
you've wasted your time just as it's
hard to wake up every morning when
you've done that the night before it's
hard to wake up consciously when that's
all you've done for lifetimes like what
that's all you've done for your whole
life yeah that's how hard it is and I
think that's why we struggle because we
all know how hard it is to just wake up
the next morning when you've had a late
night
yeah imagine you've been having late
nights in your consciousness for a long
period of time now got a special bonus
tip from Goro Gopal das on how to grow
through life that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that is time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to taking
action here we go question number one
where do you need to just wake up number
two what does balance look like for you
and number three where do you need to
practice compassion more in your life
when you want to achieve success in your
career in your academics in your
business in your profession we will fame
and that's the example of the giraffes
when the baby giraffe is born falls from
such a high distance straight on the
ground the mother's positions herself
right above the baby giraffe and guess
what she does best gives it a hard kick
butt check ajinomoto market arts a lot
party so but just my study habit I
didn't give a lot of cable news
sonica camel telesco so as it's just
coming out of the impact Jataka the
model gives a second harder kick now
that I understands where my couch keone
to its alpha Riga silsila oh this baby
giraffe starts getting up on its wobbly
legs you know on its wobbly legs and as
the baby giraffe gets up on the bobble
Elector doctor okay karana see Kanna
paddock or lot more pema he gets up and
starts running and then the mother
giraffe goes hugs the baby and starts
kissing the baby you know why because
the baby giraffes flesh is very soft and
supple and hyenas and lions love it the
mother knows that I can't be with the
baby giraffe all that I want to go and
get food for the baby how would I
protect it is lip la se la tomorrow
Otonashi k or previous it Rotana break
or LA tomorrow we are dramatically
jinda giving my mother giraffe Jessie I
have a lot Marty we fail we should get
up and we'll fail again we should get up
and like I always say don't just go
through life grow through life
if you want to know the five morning
routines that are critical for success
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there be the
kind of person that doesn't use the
snooze alarm so there's a rule there's
30 minutes I cannot touch my telephone
when I wake up